[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an meiner Seite ist Norbert
Lehmann für den Sport einen schönen
guten Abend auch von mir Israel spricht
von einer neuen Phase des
Krieges Bodentruppen im gazaastreifen
die israelische Armee verstärkt ihre
Angriffe auch aus der
Luft Solidarität mit den Palästinensern
bei einer Massenkundgebung in Istanbul
fordert Präsident Erdogan Israel auf die
Angriffe einzustellen achtung Achtung
hier ist Berlin 100 Jahre ist das jetzt
her seitdem begleitet uns das Radio im
Alltag und in historischen
Sternstunden wir beginnen in Israel vor
3 Wochen folterten und ermordeten die
Terroristen der Hamas dort 1400 Menschen
jetzt schlägt Israel noch mal härter
zurück auch mit Bodentruppen Gaza Stadt
sei ein Schlachtfeld warnt die
israelische Armee die Palästinenser die
versuchen sich auf dem abgesperrten
Landstrich irgendwie zu retten die UN
sprechen von 1,4 Millionen
Binnenflüchtlingen Israel bombardiert
den Norden des Gazastreifens aus der
Luft und vom Wasser aus am sind nach
Militärangaben Infanterie und Panzer im
Einsatz über die neuesten Entwicklungen
Tim
Kröger es ist gekommen wie vom
israelischen Militär angekündigt die
Streitkräfte haben ihre bodenoperation
in der vergangenen Nacht massiv
ausgeweitet man sei mit Infanterie
Artillerie und pioniertruppen in den
Gazastreifen einmarschiert vor allem in
den nördlichen Teil die Hamas hat
heftige Gegenwehr angekündigt es soll zu
schweren Gefechten gekommen
sein heute Nacht hat der Boden in Gaza
gebebt wir haben oberhalb und unter der
Erde
angegriffen wir haben Terroristen aller
Rangordnungen attackiert
überall die Instruktionen für die
Streitkräfte sind klar die Operation
geht weiter bis es neue Befehle
gibt das israelische Militär hat noch
einmal die Zivilbevölkerung aufgerufen
in den Süden des Gazastreifens zu
flüchten parallel zur bodenoperation
wurden offenbar die Luftangriffe
verstärkt laut vereinter Nationen seien
auch Internet und mobilfunkeinrichtungen
betroffen es sei schwierig für
Hilfsorganisationen und die Menschen in
Gaza zu
kommunizieren sie haben alle
Kommunikationswege unterbrochen keine
Anrufe kein
Internet sie haben alles unterbrochen
bevor sie einmarschiert
sind das Bombardement ist willkürlich es
wird niemand verschont egal ob Kinder
oder Erwachsene Frauen oder
die ausgeweitete israelische
bodenoperation bereitet auch den
Menschen in Israel Angst die um das
Leben der mehr als 220 Geiseln fürchten
die von der Hamas in den Gazastreifen
verschleppt
wurden unsere größte Sorge ist dass die
Armee jetzt begonnen hat im Gazastreifen
zu
operieren wir hoffen dass Sie alle
unsere Geiseln
zurückbringen es gab bereits zeitlich
begrenzte Bodenoperationen dieses Mal
aber sind die israelischen Soldaten
offenbar im Gazastreifen
geblieben Michael bewerunge ist in
sterot in der Nähe des Gazastreifens
Michael ist es jetzt die langerwartete
Bodenoffensive also ich glaube gut 24
Stunden nach Beginn dieser massiven
bodenoperation macht es keinen Sinn mehr
um den heißen Brei herumzureden Israel
ist mit starken Truppen Verbänden mit
Infanterie mit Panzer mit schwerem Gerät
an mehreren Orten in den gaserstreifen
einmarschiert der Verteidigungsminister
hat gesagt es gibt auf absehbare Zeit
keinen Rückzugsbefehl die Operationen
werden dort am Boden vor fortgesetzt das
ist der Beginn einer Bodenoffensive das
ist die Bodenoffensive Punkt zu welchem
Ende mit welchem Ziel mit welcher
Strategie das ist noch völlig unabsehbar
absehbar aber schon warum sich die Armee
und auch die politische Führung so
schwer tut das Wort Bodenoffensive in
den Mund zu nehmen da ist zum einen die
Hamas
man will die Hamas im Unklaren lassen
wann wo mit welcher Intensität am Boden
eingegriffen wird man darf sich glaube
ich auch diese Bodenoffensive nicht als
einen linearen Prozess als ein Marsch
von A nach B vorstellen das zweite sind
die Geiseln man will das Leben der
Geisel nicht gefähden die Hamas hat
angekündigt mit dem Beginn einer
Bodenoffensive mit der Ermordung der
Geiseln zu beginnen und der dritte Grund
ist vielleicht der wichtigste man will
die hebolla im Norden nicht triggern die
hat angedroht wenn die Bodenoffensive
hier im Süden beginnt dann selbst eine
Front im Norden zu eröffnen du hast die
Geiseln angesprochen für dieer heißt es
jetzt nichts Gutes
oder nein wir haben es schon gehört es
gab heute ein Treffen auch mit premier
Netanyahu der hat gesagt man werde alles
tun um das Leben der Gasen zu schützen
sie zu befreien es gab aber auch ein
sehr interessanten Satz des
Generalstabschefs HEV der hat gesagt man
werde auch alles tun um die die Geiseln
im Gazastreifen zu befreien die Soldaten
in Gaza würden alles tun das lässt
darauf schließen dass Israel vor allem
auf Befreiungsaktionen auf
Kommandoaktionen setzt da ist das Leben
der Geisel natürlich viel stärker in
Gefahr als bei Verhandlungen danke schön
Michael bungen live aus sterot die UN
volollversammlung hat mit großer
Mehrheit eine Resolution zum Krieg
beschlossen darin fordert sie eine
sofortige Waffenruhe und verurteilt
jegliche Gewalt gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung die Hamas begrüßte die
Resolution nach Ansicht von Israel
gehört sie auf den Müllhaufen der
Geschichte weil der Text die Hamas mit
keinem Wort erwähnt 120 Länder stimmten
in der Nacht in New York der Erklärung
zu 14 waren dagegen 45 enthielten sich
darunter auch Deutschland das Papier ist
ökerrechtlich nicht bindend fragen wir
Claudia Bates in Washington was zeigt
das Abstimmungsverhalten in der
UN also in der Resolution steht durchaus
vieles worauf sich im Prinzip alle
einigen können sie hebt stark ab auf den
Schutz von Zivilisten insgesamt und auf
humanitäre Hilfe für die Menschen in
Gaza es werden alle Gewaltakte und
wahllose Angriffe verurteilt und
aufgrund dieser Inhalte eben die breite
Zustimmung aber die verurteilt an keiner
Stelle die Greultaten der Hamas und auch
von Israels Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
ist nicht die Rede insofern haben die
Länder die besonders eng an Israels
Seite stehen dagegenestimmt wie z.B die
USA und hier geht man davon aus je enger
man an Israels Seite steht desto stärker
ist auch der gegebenenfalls auch
mäßigende Einfluss auf Israel
Deutschland die Enthaltung ungewöhnlich
für einen besonders engen Partner
Israels die Außenministerin sagte man
sie ja auch das Leid der Palästinenser
und PalästinenserInnen aber die
Resolution hat sich nicht klar gegen die
Taten der Hamas positioniert und
insofern kam eine Zustimmung
Deutschlands nicht in Frage warum dann
kein nein sondern eine Enthaltung also
deutschland sieht sich offenbar eher in
einer Vermittlerrolle und meinte wohl
die könne man durch eine Enthaltung eher
signalisieren als mit einem klaren Nein
Danke nach Washington Claudia
bat der Krieg im Osten bewegt auch die
Menschen in Deutschland in mehreren
Städten gab es heute Kundgebungen in
Oldenburg demonstrierten etwa 120
Menschen für Solidarität mit Israel und
gegen
Antisemitismus in München forderten rund
5000 Menschen Frieden für Gaza und ein
Ende des Krieges fast zehnm so viele wie
erwartet in der Türkei in Istanbul
gingen Hunderttausende auf die Straße um
ihre Unterstützung für die palästin n zu
demonstrieren dazu aufgerufen hatte
Präsident Erdogan er hatte seine Kritik
an Israels Angriffen auf den
Gazastreifen zuletzt deutlich verschärft
Jorg Brase
berichtet als der Präsident einschwebte
war die Bühne bereitet mehrere
hunderttausend Anhänger hatte die
regierende akpartei nach Istanbul
gerufen Solidarität mit Palästina war
das Motto Präsident Erdogan kritisierte
noch schärfer als bisher den Westen der
dem Morden Israels tatenlos zusehe
Erdogan verteidigte seine Aussage Hamas
sei keine Terrororganisation sondern
eine Befreiungsbewegung und meinte der
wahre Terrorist sei
Israel seit jetzt 22 Tagen begeht Israel
in Gaza Kriegsverbrechen wir bereiten
uns darauf vor der Welt zu zeigen dass
Israel ein Kriegsverbrecher ist und dass
alle westlichen Nationen Israel dabei
unterstützen Worte die bei den
eigentlichen Adressaten erwartungsgemäß
gut
Anken wir müssen unsere
palästinensischen Brüder verteidigen und
Israel verurteilen wir vertrauen unserem
Präsidenten er versucht das Beste zu tun
was immer Erdogan uns befieht werden wir
machen eine fanatische Menge jubelte
ihrem Präsidenten zu es wirkte mit unter
wie ein
wahlkampfaftritt Präsident erdan ist in
diesem Konflikt ganz klar Partei er mus
erklären und hat das auch mit dieser
Veranstaltung heute getan im kommenden
Jahr sind wichtige Kommunalwahlen in der
Türkei und so war sein Auftritt heute
auch ein klares Zeichen an seine
islamisch konservativen Wähler
ähnliche Jubelbilder wird es morgen
geben wenn die Türkei den 100 Jahrestag
ihrer Staatsgründung
feiert während die Welt auf die
Eskalation im Nahen Osten blickt geht
der russische Angriffskrieg in deruk
weiter nicht nur die ukrainische
Regierung fürchtet vergessen zu werden
Christian sem beginnt seinen Bericht in
nipro im Südosten des
Landes die goldene rosensynagoge in
nipro hier lebt eine der größten und
aktivsten jüdischen Gemeinden des Landes
die Ukrainer fühlen mit ihren jüdischen
Freunden merken aber dass der russische
Angriffskrieg wegen des Krieges in
Israel weniger Aufmerksamkeit
bekommt ich mache mir Sorgen und die
Welt sollte nicht vergessen was in der
Ukraine Pass
während man auch nach Israel
scha wir verstehen dass zu viele
Konflikte auf einmal zu viel sind für
die Welt und wir fürchten dass jemand
anderes mehr Hilfe braucht als
wir im Schatten des nahostkrieges setzt
Putin seinen Vernichtungskrieg gegen die
Ukraine weiter fort am schwersten sind
die Gefechte momentan rund um die Stadt
avdivka im Osten des Landes die Ukraine
hat die Stadt seit 2014 zur Festung
ausgebaut und vermient und verteidigt
sie mit allen Mitteln die Gegend ist
flacher die russischen Truppen verfügen
über keine beherrschenden Höhen wie in
der Endphase der Schlacht und bachmut
und deshalb ist es inen viel schwieriger
natürlich diese Stadt einzunehmen oder
vorwärts zu kommen der britische
Geheimdienst geht davon aus dass
Russland bei der Schlacht um avdivka mit
die schwersten Verluste in diesem Jahr
in der Ukraine erlitten hat und in nipro
versuchen die Menschen noch den
Spätherbst zu genießen trotz der
russischen Invasion und sie sagen bitte
vergesst nicht was Russland uns
antut im Iran ist eine 16-Jährige nach
mehreren Wochen im Koma gestorben
Menschenrechtler sagen die junge Frau
sei vor rund einem Monat in der
thearaner U-Bahn von der Sittenpolizei
verletzt worden weil sie kein Kopftuch
trug nach offiziellen Angaben stürzte
sie wegen niedrigen Blutdrucks der Fall
erinnert an den Tod Massa amenis sie
starb nachdem sie von der sittenpizei
festgenommen worden war aufatmen im
usbundesstaat Main mehr als zwei Tage
nach dem Amoklauf mit 18 Toten haben
Ermittler die Leiche des mutmaßlichen
Täters gefunden offenbar hat er sich
selbst erschossen mit großem Aufwand
hatte die Polizei nach dem 40-Jährigen
gefahndet ztausende Anwohner sollten
ihre Häuser nicht verlassen der
Reservist soll am Mittwoch in einem
Bowling Center und einem Restaurant auf
Menschen geschossen
haben und jetzt noch ein Hunderter
geburtstag der einem zwei Dinge bewusst
macht die Bedeutung von Medien und
todgesagte lebenlänger Christ hat lepple
über Geburtstag und Geschichte des
Radios seit 100 Jahren gibt's was auf
die Uhren das Radio eine stürmische
Geschichte vom Luxus gut für wenige zum
NS propagandain inststrument ist das
modernste vom lemedium der Aufbaujahre
zum gute Laune Begleitmedium vielfach
gut gesagt aber nach wie vor hören zwei
Drittel der Deutschen 400 verschiedene
Radioprogramme das
Erfolgsrezept Radio ist das einzige
Medium wo das Bild im Kopf entsteht
achtung Achtung hier ist Berlin im
boxhaus auf Welle 400 m 29 oktober
1923 nach der Ansage um Punkt 20 Uhr
erklingt das erste Live shellow
Konzert die Lizenz zum Hören kostet für
jeden 25
reichmark in Deutschland herrscht
Inflation hören ist Luxus und nur mit
Kopfhörer möglich Radio war zu diesem
Zeitpunkt das einzige echtzeitmedium das
war die einzige Quelle wo ich in im
Augenblick eine Nachricht hören konnte
oder einem Programm folgen konnte in den
Wirtschaftswunderjahren erlebt das Radio
seine Blütezeit unvergessen Bern
[Applaus]
194 Destiny in den 70ern sind
radioderatoren Popstars die zwei von der
quatschstelle Thomas gotschalk und
Günther Jauch sowie viele andere machen
im Radio Karriere dann setzen Fernsehen
und Internet dem hörfunkt mächtig zu
doch bis heute bleiben 50 Millionen
Deutsche dem Radio täglich treu trotz
tiktok Netflix und
Spotify wir sind hier echte Menschen mit
echten Gefühlen und ich glaube dass das
so schnell erstmal nicht aussterben wird
das Radio lebt na dann alles Gute für
die nächsten 100
Jahre ja alles Gute und glückwunsch auch
an die deutschen Fußballfrauen die haben
gestern Abend bei der nations League
geliefert 5 Z1 gegen Wales erste
Bewährungsprobe des neuen
interimstrainers Horst Rubisch
erfolgreich bestanden doch das deutsche
Team das tat sich anfangs schwer machte
dann aber in Halbzeit Z alles klar ganz
zufrieden wirkt Horst rubch nicht das
klare Resultat täuscht darüber hweg dass
ein Team eine lange Zeit braucht
Tiefpunkt der ein zu ein Ausgleich der
valiserinnen kurz vor der Pause wir
haben ja gut gespielt erste haupzeit ein
was wir nicht gemacht haben waren die
Tore das muss man ja auch ganz klar
sagen die Halbzeitansprache wirkt sofort
wieder wie schon beim 1:0 vollendet die
kopfballstarke Lea Schüller in der Folge
viele vergebene Möglichkeiten erst Julia
quin lässt mit einem platziert
geschossenen Meter 10 Minuten vor
Schluss die Anspannung abfallen gegen
einen nachlassenden Gegner und mit etwas
Glück markieren einwechselspielerinnen
weitere Tore
nkins und Nicole anomi zum erst am Ende
deutlichen 5 Z1 Sieg auf dem Weg ins
olympische Turnier zählen nur noch Siege
auf diesen ersten lässt sich zumindest
aufbauen wir haben ein eine Qualität um
diese Spieler einfach klar zu
kontrollieren man hat ja nachher auch
gesehen dass es immer immer besser wurde
die leicht verletzte Alexandra Pop wird
auch am Dienstag auf Island wieder
benötigt und sei es nur als moralische
Stütze zur Fußball buundesliga da stand
neuer nach langer Verletzung heute
wieder im bayerntor und hatte wenig zu
tun beim kanterieg gegen die libien
München demütigt Darmstadt 8:0 Gladbach
schlägt Heidenheim 2:1 Bremen gegen
Union 2:0 die Berliner mit der 10en
Niederlage in Serie Augsburg 3:2 gegen
Wolfsburg Stuttgart verliert nach sieben
Siegen in Serie gegen Hoffenheim 2:3 das
abendpiel leipzigköln bereits gestern
Bochum Mainz 2:2 die Tabelle die Bayern
übernehmen die Führung Leverkusen kann
sie morgen zurück erobern Stuttgart
Dritter V Dortmund und Hoffenheim auf
fünf die zweite Tabellenhälfte beginnt
mit Augsburg und unten Bochum 16 vor
Köln und Schlusslicht Mainz und das
Abendspiel Leipzig gegen Köln ausfülich
bei uns im Aktuellen Sportstudio 23 Uhr
zu Gast der turnweltmeister am Warren
Lukas
Dauser Olympiasieger Alexander S ist im
Viertelfinale des ATP Turniers in Wien
ausgeschieden er unterlag dem Russen
andre in 1 Z2
setzen ja und Auftag der
Wintersportsaison mit dem Weltcup
riesenlanum der Frauen in Sölden und den
hat die Schweizerin Lara gutberami
gewonnen mit nur 200 Sekunden Vorsprung
vor federika brigona aus Italien und
Petra vilova aus der Slowakei skikönigin
Mikaela schifren verpasste ihren 89
Weltcupsieg deutlich und wurde
Sechste Morgen sind die Männer dran in
Sölden Riesenslalom ab 12:45 Uhr bei uns
zu sehen ZF gut zu wissen danke schön
Langschläfer können sich freuen die
kommende Nacht wird eine Stunde länger
denn dann endet die sommerzeit heißt um
Punkt 3 stellen wir die Uhr um eine
Stunde zurück auf 2 Uhr Winterzeit aber
nicht alle Drehen am Zeiger Grönland
macht Schluss damit will die Insel die
zum Königreich Dänemark gehört ein
Stückchen näher an Europa Rücken
zumindest zeitlich statt vier Stunden
Verschiebung sind es dann nur noch
drei sonnig und sehr mild wird es morgen
nur für einige katja hornffer hat gleich
die Details zum Wetter 11:4 Uhr begrüßt
Sie Dunja Hayali im heute journal Ihnen
alles Gute ein schönes Wochenende und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend schon heute Nacht überquärt
die Warmfront von tief Benji Deutschland
nordostwärts und morgen beschäftigt uns
an die Kaltfront schon in der Nacht
kommt also neuer Regen an und am ehesten
trocken bleibt es hier südlich der Donau
dort wird's auch am kältesten mit drei
oder 2° sonst bleibt die Nacht bei 12
bis 5° milder und morgen erwarten uns
Höchsttemperaturen meist um 14
im südlichen Bayern und im südlichen
BadenWürttemberg gibt's dagegen 17 bis
20° der Regen der Nacht erreicht morgen
die Ostsee und zwischen süld und der
Odermündung gibt's dann Regenschauer und
Gewitter es schließt sich ein
freundlicher Streifen an von den
Ostfriesischen Inseln bis zum Erzgebirge
und dabei gibt es einen sehr frischen
starken Südwestwind und in den Bergen
gibt's sogar stürmische böhnen oder
sturmböhnen viel Wind gibt's morgen auch
im Westen und es kann kräftig regnen
hier zwischen dem Saarland und der pfals
können innerhalb von 48 Stunden bis
Montagabend durchaus 35 bis 50 l regenfu
Quadratmeter fallen am oberrein sind
morgen auch einige Gewitter nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen zwischen dem Bodensee und
dem Erzgebirge wird es freundlich das
liegt am Föhn den gibt's auch noch am
Montag mit Werten bis 20° der Dienstag
wird kühler und der november beginnt
dann sehr mild und sonnig am Mittwoch
guten
Abend